listen to this Carly sources say DHS
secretary Alejandra mearis told border
patrol agents that up more than
85% that's a whopping number of migrants
at the border are released into the US
Fox is also told that my Arcus shared
the stat after he was asked about this
comment he made last
week would it be surprised you to hear
that CBP sources say that currently they
are releasing More than 70% of the
migrants crossing every day and
sometimes more than that number higher
than 70% would that surprise
you it would not it would not surprise
me at all I know the data and I will
tell you that when individuals are
released they are released into
immigration enforcement
proceedings Michigan congressman John
James just visited the southern border
with speaker Johnson last week and he
joins me now great to have you here in
person Congressman um look I'm no math
major and I understand the math rules
have changed throughout Society but when
I was in school 85 was more than 70 so
did Alejandra mycus just lie to Brett
Bear on our air absolutely and he's been
lying to the American people for years
um since Joe Biden took uh took office
there have been hundreds of thousands
millions of illegal aliens released into
our borders and when they are examined
uh then we have to take them at their
word their name their origin their date
of birth we don't know who these people
are right now this is not just people
from Mexico it's not just people from
Central and South America they're people
from all over the world and right now
with our open border right now with wars
in the Middle East right now with the
world on fire every day in America where
we have an open border is October 6th
for Israel in America every day is
September 10th in America with this open
border under the Biden Administration
and secretary maor's failure such a
great point I don't think we can even
begin to Fathom the consequences of what
85% of these migrants being in our
country we don't know who they are we
don't know where they came from we don't
know what they're doing here I don't
think we can fathom the consequences of
that and you apt to say October 6 as the
analogy as a military guy got to get
your thoughts on this John Kirby says
President Biden has no plan to dismiss
defense secretary Lloyd Austin after his
secret hospitalization so Congressman
apparently the Secretary of Defense
going a wall is no big deal for this
white house it's just kind of
run-of-the-mill what would happen to you
when you were in the Army if you went
awall look the very first thing you
learned on the first day of basic
training Lloyd Austin and I are both
West Point graduates the first thing we
learn is general order number one I will
guard everything with the limits of my
post and only quit my post properly
relieved it is a major issue that Lloyd
Austin uh was essentially absent without
leave but what I'm most concerned with
is the health of the sixth in line to
the presidency the health of this man
the Secretary of Defense and the health
of United States military we need to get
this Administration focused on what it's
going to take to fight and win this
nation's War it's not their woke agenda
we need to refocus on what it's going to
take to keep this nation safe which is
why we need to change this
Administration over in November 2024 I'm
worried about the chain of command I
mean I'm not a milit AR guy but I'm told
chain of command is important we need to
know who's making orders especially when
we're doing missions like we did when
Austin was absent know we need to have
healthy people we need to have healthy
people uh keeping our nation safe and uh
this raises a lot of questions about the
type of culture and the type of
administration Joe Biden is running this
is just another a long line of failures
before we let you go you went to West
Point undergrad but you did a little
grad work at University of Michigan how
happy are you today hey you know what go
Blue go team won 44 God bless you all
those seniors stayed back to finish the
job and they got it done last night this
is the greatest team in human history
and they have an enthusiasm unknown to
Mankind and they got the job done
congratulations guys in the interest of
your electoral interest I'm not going to
ask you what you would want to say to
the Michigan State Spartan fans this
morning I'm going to keep it classy San
Diego congressman John James thanks so
much thanks for being here have a great
day sir I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme
and I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis